you're known around these parts like
everybody heard you were coming here and
all the ladies they call you as a D do
you know what is a D is not exactly we
well I I actually don't either like I
didn't know what is that he was either
so I had to get some of my staff to tell
us okay Kayla where are you at daddy
what does daddy well for whatever reason
Kelly kids today feel like being a dad
is lame for some reason they think dad
jokes are lame dad jeans are lame
but the fact of the matter is there's
nothing lame about being a dad and a dad
is a man who might be a little bit more
seasoned but it still has that youthful
zest you feel
that's what disease coming from and Jeff
is a prime example of this I mean check
out this fit y'all have seen his
Instagram daddy all day long like a MILF
is that what that ads for like women or
is that not daytime he probably can't
say that
you can't say that on daytime jab that's
just crude I'm so sorry did you come
here in just I don't know how I can make
it up to you know what do you think
about being a daddy I like being a dad
like I'm still trying to enter
understand a definition I think I think
I get it I think it's complimentary it's
very calm very much but I like being a
daddy that opened up a whole new world a
cool world yeah I thought I loved my
life and then I had kids being pregnant
with them was horrible but afterwards
I'm straight yeah I want to hear about
all of that but I saw been watching the
show I saw your kids on the show when
they came out ran to and hug you I
started to get weepy just and just
seeing it they're so cute yeah my
daughter is definitely I'm gonna have to
like I'm gonna have to Kendrick Lamar
humble that one down yeah she's yeah
she's so I love it she's bold but she
has never met a stranger and definitely
loves attention really I don't know
where she gets it from job I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this